of the media are getting slammed for
pushing a narrative that border patrol
agents on horseback were using quote
whips on haitian migrants crossing the
southern border but that was before they
got all of their facts several headlines
stated agents were holding whips and
rounding up and chasing down migrants
turns out dhs and the border patrol say
they did not have whips but of course it
wasn't just headlines that claimed
agents were in fact using whips watch
should we be looking at the budget of
department of homeland security because
i was not aware that whips people had
that kind of equipment on them that they
could use on humans the fact that we are
dealing with
mainly black
migrants and black immigrants and asylum
seekers at our border in this kind of
way really speaks to the the kind of
racism systematic racism that is
embedded in that department it does
smack of a bygone era
of slavery
aided by reports of people being beaten
whether with a riding crop or the reigns
most likely
you may be drawn to the desperation of
the man trying to escape
others in the desperation of keeping our
borders safe
of what
i believe the former president tried to
depict as a brown menace at our border
they are so quick to confirm their own
biases aren't they emily a border patrol
agent telling fox news categorically we
do not carry whips
of course they don't but you know what
chris cuomo is right those people are
desperate there is desperation there and
where was the media covering it for the
last months where was the media covering
the desperation of those miners who were
complaining of sexual assault who were
going to the bathroom in bags who were
crying hysterically and who could not
even lay down full length because they
were so on top of each other where was
the media covering when district
attorneys throughout all of the states
the entire country raised the alarm over
the concerns over the lack of background
checks there at those emergency shelters
where was the media covering when people
said these humans these human migrants
are living in squalid conditions in
their own excrement only now
if they have issues with equipment if
they have issues with the surge then we
need more funding we need more coverage
we need more people to listen to law
enforcement down there to local
officials down there who have been
crying for help from the federal
government and from the media for
coverage of these desperate humans yes
and the desperation of the americans who
are trying to enforce the laws and to
create a habitable legal constitutional
and safe situation for everyone involved
you know
emily you hit the nail on the head
because what you're asking is what is
the measure of our outrage
when do
people just as human beings being put in
horrible conditions trigger us to do the
right thing do we have to wait until
there's a category of people that people
might care more about
see i i care about that child who was
put over that wall and dropped into
america remember that yes um and
fortunately border agents caught that
baby i didn't care that the child was
from central america nigeria it didn't
matter to me where
he or she came from
and i i think that that measuring our
outrage is really important and it's
because we have had it out of control
for a while
right oh we only care about this when it
tilts this way it's because of that that
we ignore the facts of the story first
of all
there should never be a situation where
you feel because of covet and everything
else you're outnumbered i mean when you
look at the numbers they had to bring in
squad cars to build a barrier to keep
people from coming into the country on
saturday i mean look at the reporting by
bill mollusion
they should never have had to do that
and the whips let's talk about it
those images are heartbreaking and
unfortunate
those are split straps i'm not an
equestrian genius okay i've ridden a
horse i i live in arizona part of the
year emily however knows her stuff
okay
and and they weren't whips
but it's easy to buy into whatever the
narrative is and the optics on the
screen and in the pictures because
they're on horses and and we we put the
best among us
with people in the worst positions
and it does look bad
take it to 16 pennsylvania avenue would
you
let him know how much it hurts to see
this
and ask him why they waited this long
yeah meanwhile abc's cnn cbs they all
just ran with the story well they were
changing lower thirds on the screen
today you were watching it yes without
making a single call though you know
they could have picked up the phone and
done some reporting it reminds me of the
ivermectin story do you remember when
rolling stones came out with that
horrible article suggesting that people
were overdosing on horse tranquilizer
and gunshot victims weren't being
treated it was false but they ran with
it because in oklahoma a state that
votes red it confirmed their narrative
i want you to talk about how they change
the words on the bottom of the screen on
one of the networks right that that
network earlier today changed it from
the word whip to using rains to using
rains in a whipping fashion and i and
we're precise here with our language
pieces that's exactly right and it said
appeared they changed it exactly to
portray what is what appears on that
video rather than pushing that narrative
that they have been this whole time but
that we had we were showing earlier look
at that big picture on our big wall i
mean it is frightening in any regard
because these people are so and emily
used the word desperate of course they
are look at what they're willing to go
through just to be here now we'll see
if biden becomes obama and becomes the
the moniker of deporter-in-chief we're
going to see if he tries to fix an
immigration problem that he started by
getting rid of people that you see on tv
by the way what about the ones that are
fanning out across the country that we
don't know maybe leo in here guys uh one
quick point leo the white house has
thrown fuel on this um and the dhs
secretary it's really interesting leo to
listen to his change in tone i want to
play that sound bite and i'll make a
quick point and come to you leo on the
other end
images have come out of border patrol
agents whipping haitian immigrants so my
question to you do you think that's a
humane way to treat migrants you are
assuming facts if i may say respectfully
uh you are assuming facts uh that uh not
yet been determined to ensure control uh
of the horse long reigns are used but we
are going to investigate the facts to
ensure that the situation is as we
understand it to be and if it's anything
different we will respond accordingly
any mistreatment or abuse of a migrant
is unacceptable
is against border patrol policy training
and our department's values we are very
troubled by what we have seen i was
horrified by what i saw
leo so he changed from saying he didn't
see anything unacceptable to now he's
horrified intervening fact happened
between those comments jinsaki at the
podium said she was horrified he used
her exact words when asked about it a
second time i'm wondering if the press
secretary or the white house picked up
the phone and said hey get on board with
us here change your tune leo
oh uh you're right kaylee again because
let me tell you right now the damage has
been done not only are they playing this
card about the whips they're playing
which drives me nuts the race card
they're you hear the slavery argument
and the damage has been done
people have heard it already even if
they make a correction
the damage has been done the sickening
use of the race card when it can be used
to ignore the refugee camps that is the
democratic playbook at its finest it's
sydney as a civil rights attorney i find
it repulsive i'm sick of the democrats
playing the race card
well we all can't go to the press
briefing at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
yeah if we could maybe we could ask
these questions
because they need to be answered from
the president himself i would love to
hear leo for one asking questions jim
zaki or our great journalist harris
faulkner